il est
le thermomètre affiche moins 10 degrés
mais avec le vent la température
ressentie approche les -20
dans ces régions polaires ou le moindre
déplacement est un défi un français a
décidé de vivre l'aventuré
[Musique]
de quoi que les chiens qui travaillent à
45 ans nicolas dubreuil est un
explorateur du bout du monde
il a découvert le groenland il y a une
vingtaine d'années il y vit plusieurs
mois par an
aujourd'hui avec nils un de ses amis
inuits ils partent chasser le phoque
[Musique]
ça c'est sûr que tu regrettes un peut
pas avoir de motoneige mais autant dans
la montagne c'est efficace mais sur la
banquise en fait les chiens ils sont
capables de repérer les zones de glace
mince et la motoneige évidemment pas du
tout donc c'est pour ça qu'ils utilisent
sur la banquise utilise que des chiens
mais moi de toute façon je n'ai que des
chiens si je voulais voyager en
motoneige je serais obligé d'en louer
une et puis je préfère vraiment
l'attelage de chiens c'est dans ma
culture
nicolas est un nomade qui passe le plus
clair de son temps en expédition
à ski à pied ou en traîneau il parcourt
le grand nord à la recherche de
territoires sauvages
il est devenu l'un des meilleurs
spécialistes des régions polaires
au groenland il se sent chez lui c est
tendu comme ça
immense à l'infini à rien du tout il n'y
a que de la glace on est forcément
émerveillé on al impression là on a ces
icebergs qui sont pris dans la banquise
c'est quelque chose qui est on a
l'impression d'être sur la lune une fois
qu'on a une fois qu'on a vécu la
banquise il n'y a plus qu'une étape
après c'est d'aller sur la lune ou sur
mars
avec le réchauffement climatique
l'épaisseur de la glace se réduit les
voyages deviennent de plus en plus
périlleux
ce qui m'attire c'est un petit peu tout
ça c'est à dire la nature extrême le
danger forcément mais tout c'est toutes
ces choses qu'ils font qu'on sent outils
fois plus vivre
sur cette terre inuits où rien ne pousse
chasser est une nécessité
s'ils veulent manger ce soir nils et
nicolas doivent trouver un phoque
shoot many rapport
sur
nicolas et nice scrute l'horizon
lorsque les phoques sortent de l'eau et
se repose sur la banquise ils sont
visibles à des kilomètres
tous les groenlandais ont le droit de
chasser le phoque et c'est uniquement
pour la nourriture et la peau elle
utilise comme nous on utilise on
consomme tout dans le cochon dans la
vache buzz c'est pareil consomme tout
dans le dans le phoque
la traque dure depuis de longues heures
déjà neil favori garde est partout
aucune tache noire dans l'immensité
blanche
on en aura pas de la journée
judas qui chope le temps est mauvais
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de phoques je
suis vraiment déçu quand ya pas assez de
soleil les phoques ne sentent pas
au groenland la patience est de rigueur
on apprend très tôt à vivre au rythme de
la nature
si on trouve rien bon mange rien c'est
la loi un peu ici ça m'est arrivé de de
faire trois quatre jours comme ça où on
n'a rien chasser rien pêcher et ils sont
pas tellement dans le dans la prévision
du lendemain donc ils prennent pas de
nourriture avec eux si fait que ben on
mange rien on boit du thé ou café
heureusement la banquise réserve parfois
de belles surprises
au loin nils a repéré un campement de
pêcheurs de tenter quelques hommes
attendent depuis des jours que le
poisson morde
la technique de pêche est ancestrale
elle consiste à creuser un trou dans la
glace pour y poser une ligne
suite à défaut de phoques nicolas et
niels espère trouver du poisson
salut vu comment ça va bien et vous nous
aussi on vient d'arriver
ça fait longtemps que vous êtes là oui
ça fait quelques jours nils connaissait
pêcheurs ils habitent dans le même
village que lui
et vous avez du fret on
a pêché quelques-uns
la pêche n'a pas été très bonne tu mais
il reste encore quelques flétan
à celui-là les gros seins il pèse
combien
je ne sais pas trop clinton
jps une tonne
il est lourd non il fait juste
le flétan fond c'est l'un des poissons
les plus pêcher dans les eaux froides du
groënland les imitent apprécié sa chère
grâce
particulièrement riche en protéines
nicolas profite de chaque rencontre pour
se rapprocher un peu plus des inuits
crime août s'est mis alors nous vous
rapportez votre pêche en traînant
jusqu'au village en passant par la
montagne oui on prend le même chemin
vous avez près pour venir
oui mais ça monte drôlement ça va c'est
pas trop dur non pas de problème
ce soir grâce aux pêcheurs
nicolas et niels ne boiront pas que du
thé
fin de la journée
après cinq heures de traîneau les chiens
sont affamés
ils sont précieux pour les inuits qui ne
peuvent pas vivre sans eux atk report
voilà ça ils ont tous un prénom est par
exemple celui là il s'appelle yuki
ota maintenant qui les a nourris il va
tout s'est attaché à une à une ligne
pour qu'ils passent la nuit
femmes kilos
avant d'atterrir au bout du monde
nicolas passait le plus clair de son
temps assis derrière un bureau dans un
amphi bondé
à la faculté de strasbourg il enseigne l
informatique et ses expéditions polaires
n'étaient que des parenthèse de quelques
semaines
cette vie elle devenait de plus en plus
insupportable en fait j'étais de moins
en moins satisfaits et puis c'est passé
à un accident je suis tombée pendant une
expédition au groenland sur la banquise
au nord du groenland au mois de février
- 35 la banquise a cassé je suis tombé à
l'eau c'est un accident très grave j'ai
fais vraiment perdre la vie par deux
fois en plus j'ai eu les deux mains
gelées les deux pieds gelés on voulait
même amputé des mains et des pieds
et
cet accident au lieu de me dire bon t'es
allé trop loin
arrête-toi retourne à la fac soit bien
tranquille arrête de faire ça
ça a été exactement contraire cela je me
suis dit
on n'a qu'une vie on le pense tous à
tout le monde se dit ça on n'a qu'une
vie sauf que le jour où on le pense
sincèrement
là on se dit il faut vivre que les
choses qu'on aime et donc j'ai tout
quitté pour ne vivre plus que de l'
aventure et en particulier de l'aventuré
polaire
nicolas a abandonné le confort des
grandes villes par amour pour un désert
blanc
au groenland près de 90% du territoire
est inhabitable
recouvert par la calotte glaciaire
sur cette île qui appartient encore au
danemark on compte la plus faible
densité de population au monde
seulement 56 mille habitants pour un
pays trois fois plus grand que la france
nicolas gagne désormais sa vie comme
guide polaire dans cet environnement
hostile ils veillent sur la sécurité de
scientifiques de touristes ou de
sportifs
en ce moment ils préparent une
expédition à ilulissat une petite ville
du sud-ouest du pays
nicolas attend un groupe de français
qu'il va faire plonger dans les eaux
glacées de la côte
lola et descend en dessous d'eux en
dessous de -1° donc on a les détendeurs
spéciaux des combinaisons spécifiques et
puis ça nécessite aussi un matin un
petit peu particulier comme ça on n'a
pas vraiment l'habitude de plonger avec
ça mais en fait c'est juste une hache
qui va nous permettre de casser briser
la banquise qui est en train de se
former
malgré son accident en 2001 il continue
de plonger
retourner dans l'eau froide comme ça à
chaque plongée je fais sous la banquise
ou ou au pied des icebergs
c'est vraiment un moment pour moi de ré
affronter et de me dire c'est pas grave
on y retourne regarde tout se passe bien
[Musique]
depuis qu'il a frôlé la mort nicolas a
changé de vie
aujourd'hui il veut donner du sens à ce
qu'il fait
avant j'en ai beaucoup de grands
sportifs
beaucoup de gens qui à la rigueur et pu
aller sans ces régions là sans moi ou
faire ses exploits sans moi et je me
suis dit que la vie était pas là je me
suis promis que
si je m'en sortais si je récupérerai
mais doit facilement sortait bien et que
je pouvais encore faire des expéditions
polaires
j'emmènerai des gens à qui on a dit que
ce n'était pas possible
ici les avions qui secoue soit en retard
soit en avance
là il a un peu en retard mais quasiment
rien c'est bon by dariole aventure
commence
nicolas accueille l'association un
sourire un espoir pour la vie une
association qui est des jeunes gravement
malades ou handicapés
évidemment pas me faire coucou lui sur
le tarmac une drôle de petite troupe
foulent le sol du groenland pour la
première fois
l'association est présidée par pascal
olmeta en venant groenland l'ancien
gardien de but veut aider 3 rêve va se
réaliser
des excédents jean paul ii garçons qui
se sont battus contre un cancer mais
aussi celui de thierry un ancien
policier qui a perdu ses deux bras dans
un accident
voilà ils sont tous complètement fêlé et
ils ont absolument voulu venir se
baigner ici au groenland il ya quelque
chose qui est pas évident en se
confrontant à des conditions extrêmes
ils veulent montrer que tout est
possible c'est un truc un petit peu
fort de vous en souvenir assez longtemps
il neige depuis un moment là depuis
quelques jours
nicolas partagent les mêmes valeurs que
l'association de pascal olmeta il va
servir de guide bénévolement ça va être
exceptionnel parce que ça va être de la
découverte pour de la découverte sur de
la découverte pour de la découverte
allez les gars y voit c'est pour donner
à tout le monde
d'être extraordinaire france
chez roth conjure
la regarde regarde chacun ses goûts là
sans déconner
et là tu vois tout ce que tu vois là au
bord c'est le pied de banquise c'est à
dire cela c'est de la banquise
hyper glissant un peine arrivée nicolas
emmène l'équipe dans les fjords
ilulissat
constellé d'icebergs
classée au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco l'endroit est sublime mais la
beauté des lieux ne doit pas faire
oublier le danger ici principale cause
de mort des des pêcheurs et des
chasseurs c'est la chute à l'eau c'est à
dire que tu peux te dire voilà on tombe
à l'eau bon ben c'est on al'impression
ok je vais me ressaisir je vais faire je
n'en fût talo entre trois et cinq
minutes de survie très qui
verse voiture ça tient 7e
mais il est quand même pas mal dix ans
il est vachement poli parlée par les
icebergs
tu vois là tu as toute une partie qui
est fait tout ça c'est une partie qui
est
qui et de la mer rouge l'époque
thierry a l'habitude de nager mais dans
les eaux chaudes de la méditerranée
s'aperçoit que bon c'est pas c'est pas
si facile que ça pas si simple c'est pas
si simple mais tu vois là là le problème
c'est que toute la petite glace c'est
réglo mais ray et là tu as des plaques
comme des plaque de banquise qui se
forment donc là on peut pas passer
un mois entier pour les douars
le premier contact avec l'eau du
groenland est plutôt saisissant ti non
mais attends 5 secondes
les jeunes n'ont que quelques jours pour
se mettre à l'eau si toutefois ils ne
changent pas d'avis je suis pas prêt
non mais jeannette maman et non mais
c'est bon ça pique la température qui
sait
au walhalla ouais ouais ouais ouais
ouais c'est ça qui tient davantage
à ilulissat
l'association s'est installée dans ce
grand hangar transformé en appartements
après le décès de ses parents morts tous
les deux d'un cancer pascal olmeta a mis
sa notoriété au service de jeunes
malades
quand je vais à madrid de voir zizou
j'amène un enfant quand je vais à
manchester que le parrain de
l'association c'est sir alex ferguson
ici on est accueillis on est dans les
vestiaires c'est le rêve de l'enfant
quand on va en afrique du sud c'est
parce qu'il ya des rêves d'enfants et ça
c'est le plus important c'est voilà
leurs yeux leurs sourires qu'on soit au
groenland conçoit ailleurs qu'on soit
voilà c'est tout ce qu'on peut capter et
ne se plaignent jamais
l excellence paul échangent leurs
premières photos avec les membres de
l'association rester en france
du succès
ils se sont rencontrés lors d'un
précédent voyage organisé par pascal
olmeta
tous deux ont connu les angoisses de la
maladie et la solitude des hôpitaux
a tous eu notre part de galette ou en
soit ça montre bien connais on n'est pas
les seuls annakin pire beau
c'est
celle ci une femme nie pas d'échanger
avec
d'autres enfants d'autres adultes de
l'association qui ont eu des dégâts là
aussi ça fait chaud au coeur
nicolas abandonne ses invités pour aller
dîner chez son ami nils
au menu bien sûr du phoque on va faire
la soupe à sac la célèbre soul de
phoques
surtout aux choux géant mais combien de
morceaux de phoque pour faire la soupe
finisse ou naouna choix mais tout à bon
je mets tout
et puis je mets ça comment on dit ça
déjà en inuit
comment
ça c'est les oignons oui des oignons il
faut les couper en petits morceaux
depuis l'arrivée des inuits au groenland
il y a un peu plus de mille ans cet
animal est leur principale source de
nourriture
est payé
hormis les produits de la chasse ou de
la pêche sur cette île tout est importé
que manger de la nourriture fraîche
c'est très important pour moi
donc là c'est pas la nourriture qu'il y
a dans les magasins qui pourra
m'apporter les vitamines et l'énergie
dont j'ai besoin pour colas
une soupe de sang de la viande de phoque
bouillie le plat typique du groënland
c'est super bon vous êtes très
énergétiques en plus
avant de venir lente et invités fonnier
recton couteau
oui
je croyais à l' éclatement la brune au
regard des touches mais
oui
la seule entorse à la modernité c'est le
bris et les oignons mais sinon il ya 200
ans venue manger comme ça
pour tout connaître des inuits nicolas a
appris à parler leur langue sortie
collage heureux que la langue c'est une
part importante de la culture ici au
début ça m'a surpris parce qu'ici il y à
des danois qui sont là depuis des années
et qui ne parle pas le groenland est
alors que nicolas lui parle super mais
ils sont très communicant donc ils font
des efforts et qu'on dit bonjour merci
au revoir du d'histoire là là tu parles
super bien non et demandait c'est pas
vrai mais ils sont tellement content
finalement qu'on parle leur langue
cinquante six mille habitants avec 56
mille personnes qui parlent cette langue
donc évidemment que dès qu'on
s'intéresse à leur culture et ont tout
de suite une envie de le transmettre
très très forte
ce soir le ciel est dégagé
si la météo le permet demain les jeunes
pourront réaliser leurs rêves
alex et ange paul s'apprête à se mettre
à l'eau
même au soleil la température extérieure
est fraîche -10 degrés
cette fois
malgré ses doutes alex ne peut plus
reculer t'es pas trop sérieux
nicolas et pascal sont là pour
l'encourager
oui mais
bute en fait c'était attiré anges et
alex à aller se baigner
réalisés étaient pour le piège jolie
comédie réalisé un rêve quoi
pierre
très petit mot
euros
à ilulissat au groenland la température
de l'océan et de -1 degré à l'excès en
vol sont à l'eau nicolas est prêt à
réagir en cas de problème
l'exploration peut commencer
tu vois glisser là
attendent le mouille pas tes affaires
est là
comment c'était c'est magnifique
magnifique
incroyable est en fait un peu froid
quand tu es dedans c'est jusqu'à 12 ans
alors vous avez été temple à
je m'aime pas je pense qu'elle a
beaucoup qui ont pas te croire tant que
tu leur as pour montrer les photos et
justement c'est
surtout encore
nicolas et pascal ont réalisé leur rêve
d'alex et d'ange paul maintenant c'est
au tour de thierry
ce matin des bourrasques de neige
s'abattent sur elodie sat
les conditions météo sont beaucoup trop
dangereuse pour envisager la moindre
sortie en mer
tout le monde se retrouve à l'abri dans
le gymnase de la ville
[Applaudissements]
les inuits sont passionnés de pêche de
chasse mais aussi de football
pas besoin de traducteur la complicité
s'installe naturellement entre pascal et
ses coéquipiers du jour
ce qu'ils sont en droit
que le voit quand il frappe comme ça
t'as vu le brabant et savent où le
maître
à jouer au football sur la glace tout
simplement parce que la nature
l'imposent une faculté d'adaptation qui
fascine nicolas
à main
pour moi ça a été des rencontres
incroyables avec un peuple est quand
même passé en 300 ans
on peut dire du néolithique à internet
et donc cette faculté d'adaptation je
pense personnellement nous manque
énormément dans nos pays on l'a perdu
c'est ça qui m'a complètement il tonné
quoi
là
où un goûter rapport à chaud de porc on
a plein de matériel a amené au bord de
l'eau
ayew mais là
ça tu fous ils vont nous aider la météo
permet enfin à thierry de plongée mais
qui s'il est ou non ça c'est fragile
impôts vraiment que ce soit un grand
quine qui sort
bon ok ce qui va prendre ça
et c'est un crime arrachés attention
c'est fragile
la plupart des enfants inuits ne savent
pas nager beaucoup ont peur de l'eau
tous veulent voir cet étranger venu
défier les eaux polaires
déjà pour moi c'est carrément l'inconnu
que je n'ai jamais nagé à une eau qui
est en dessous de zéro donc ça pour moi
c'est la grande inconnue
en cas de problème nicolas aidé d'un ami
sera sous l'eau pour secourir tiré
[Musique]
au milieu de la glace qui s'est reformé
le nageur devra se frayer un chemin
wendy m'a gentiment
[Musique]
vraiment beaucoup
thierry réalise enfin son rêve
dans l'eau le handicap est oubliée
pendant une demi heure ils nagent au
milieu des icebergs
[Musique]
je pense avoir froid et non c'est très
agréable
père
l'eau est très claire et puis bon voir
les albert ii de dessous c'est
impressionnant on s'attend pas moi c'est
quelque chose de magique qui va laisser
des traces
moi j'en reviens pas avant at est super
à l'aise
chapeau 1 bravo il avait un rêve
incroyable
qui devait rester à l'état de rêve et
puis ben c'est la réalité tout d'un coup
en quelques secondes j'ai vu l'enfant
qu'il était quand il était tout petit
quoi on était là tous les deux je
faisais des photos de lui on est au
milieu des icebergs dans une eau à moins
20 degrés que je le vois avec le sourire
jusque là t'as pour moi c'est un cadeau
de choix j'en avais les larmes aux yeux
sous le masque quoi
fin de l'aventuré
nicolas fait découvrir son pays
d'adoption à alex thiery ange paul plus
important encore il leur a transmis sa
passion du groenland
comme toujours entre deux expéditions il
part se ressourcer dans la nature
[Musique]
cette volonté toujours deux de partir
plus loin dans des endroits à vierge de
découvrir des choses de faire vivre
justement le petit gamin qui est en toi
qui dit qu'il va partir à l'aventuré
livre ses rêves que de se dire que tout
est possible que y'a rien qui peut
arrêter et il faut il faut le nourrir ça
c'est un vilain virus qu'on doit nourrir
régulièrement je pourrai jamais
m'arrêter
d'autres aventures attend nicolas ce
français du bout du monde qui a fait du
groenland sa maison et des inuits sa
famille